Hello, everybody!
Oh my god, sorry.
I'm sorry.
I've been late again.
I'm so...
I... Oh, there was... You guys didn't... We're not reading... We're not reading the pre-chat.
Sorry, my brain is, like, frazzled.
I've been awake since, like, 8.30 in the morning, so I'm so tired.
I went to bed at, like, 2 a.m.
because I was working late at night.
I was working a lot.
And, uh... And, uh, I was... Oh my gosh.
Um... So, and I've been... My brain is just all over the place.
I was gonna say, like... I was gonna, like, get some coffee or, like, GamerSupps or something.
By the way, we used TokiBerry for 10% off of GamerSupps.
Um... Just so my brain can... Oh my gosh.
My brain can, like, get kickstarted or something.
Be like...
Rav up that brain right now.
Um... But, yes.
Uh, I was late because, um... Uh, my cleaner was here today.
Um... She was here since 9 in the morning.
And it's now at 1 p.m.
Um... And, uh... And so, um...
Is that cleaner single, Toki?
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, BrokenBud.
Um... So, uh, new cleaner... Uh... A new cleaner, uh... Came in today.
Um... I usually have a different cleaner...
That comes by, but I think maybe she was busy for today.
Um... And so, um... And... Uh, she was like, Oh, what do you want... How do you want me to clean this?
And I was just like, Oh, just, you know, clean my office.
Clean the bedroom.
Uh... The kitchen area.
Uh... And all that stuff.
But I gave her a new task.
I had, like, a bunch of, like, boxes.
From, like, packages that have been sent.
Like, it was, like, giant pile of boxes.
And, um... I asked her if she could de- de- de- de-assemble these boxes.
And, like, fly in them.
Because I don't know how to do it.
Um...
I don't know how to do it properly.
So, I was like, Well, I'm just gonna hoard all these boxes.
Until... Sorry.
Disassemble.
I was gonna... I'm gonna hoard all these boxes.
From all these packages I got.
From, like, Amazon.
Gamer Soaps.
Um...
P.O.
Box.
P.R.
Boxes.
And all that stuff.
And then, like...
And I'll have the cleaner disassemble them for me.
Because I don't know how to do that.
Uh...
I don't know how to flatten it properly.
And it seems very hard.
And...
And a lot of work.
Uh...
And then I was like, Oh, could you do that too?
Until she did.
So...
Um...
So, anyway.
Uh...
No.
It's like...
You gotta cut it a certain way.
And then you gotta...
Flatten it.
And that's...
So much energy.
And I'm...
So tired.
I'm...
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you more of the super chat.
Thank you.
The keycap breakdown boxes.
Thank goodness.
She is a great streamer.
Anyway.
Um...
But, like...
She was like, Oh, you...
Are you okay if I rearrange stuff?
And I was like, Yeah, that's fine.
But, like...
And then I was like, Okay, I'm gonna take a nap in my bed.
I'm gonna be in my bedroom taking a nap.
So you can do...
You can clean all of this first.
And then do the bedroom last.
Because...
I'm...
I'm gonna take a nap.
Because I'm really tired.
By the way, I ended up not taking a nap.
Because I had to lock dad in my bedroom.
Because he was being a little...
Bitch boy.
Because he could hear...
Things...
I didn't want him to, like, interfere with the cleaning.
But the cleaning lady...
This cleaning lady actually is not...
Afraid of dogs.
But then I didn't want him to, like...
Interfere with the cleaning lady.
With the cleaning.
So then I was like, Okay, you're gonna be in my bedroom.
And you're gonna stay locked in here...
For a while.
Until, like, she's done.
But then, because he was a little bitch boy, he kept like whimpering, he kept making noises.
At first he was like barking and stuff and I showed him the bark.
I was like, don't bark!
And then he's like, oh I know, okay, I won't do that anymore.
And then he started whimpering and he's like, but I hear things outside!
There's someone outside!
There's someone
outside!
I hear them!
Let me out!
Let me see who it is!
But he knows who's outside, it's literally the cleaning lady.
So it's like, like it's not gonna be anything different.
He's like, the voices!
I hear the voices in my eyes!
Thank you for the 10 gift of ships, thank you, thank you!
Anyway, so like he's just, he was just like making so many noises and stuff.
While I was trying to sleep.
So I couldn't sleep, I couldn't take my nap.
And then like, I was like, fine, I'll just, I'll just live with it.
I'll, I'll, I'll stay up.
Please let me out so I can start flirting with that pretty lady!
How dare you, Doki!
Restricting him from pretty ladies!
He was like, she was like, right there!
And you had to close that door on him!
He was so close, yet so far at the same time!
Anyway, so, okay, so then, you know, obviously I couldn't sleep so I came out and I like looked at my desk and like, almost everything was gone from my desk!
So, I was, you know, when she was like, oh, can I like rearrange things a little?
And I was like, yeah, sure!
I didn't expect to see like, my floor, incredibly clean!
There were boxes on my floor, there were like, socks on my floor, there was like, you know, like maybe like a receipt or two that I just didn't pick up.
And then, like, my two desks, I have two tables, like, one on the side and one where my, you know, my old setup is.
Um, and then, uh, I was just like, where is it?
Like, my water was gone, my vitamins were gone, um, um, I had like a lot of, like, paper and stuff on my other desk right here.
And then, I was just like, oh my god, it's all gone!
Like, I was just like, where did everything go?
I don't even remember half the things that were on my desk.
It was just like, I, there was just, it's just empty now, other than my streaming setup.
Um, so I was like, so surprised.
I did not realize when she was like, uh, oh, um, you can't rearrange stuff.
She would actually like, you know, fix my life.
Like...
But yeah, she even like, you know, put my socks in the, in the washing machine for me and everything.
She like, picked up my socks and just put it in there.
I was so surprised.
My other cleaner didn't do that.
Um, she would like, leave things where she's like, she like, wouldn't touch stuff if like, you know, she'd be like, ooh, like, ooh, I don't know if I should touch it.
So, um, um, but then the other maid didn't fucking care.
Like, the other, the other cleaner, the other cleaner didn't even fucking care.
She was like, this is a problem.
And then literally just like, put everything away.
Like, she owned the place.
So I was very surprised.
Um, the only issue is that, I don't know where anything is right now.
Like, she was like, oh yeah, I rearranged all your stuff in your cupboards and your drawers and everything.
So I'm like, oh, so I don't know where anything is at the moment.
I, I, I, I, what I, my most fear is just the fact that like, I'm scared she, um, she threw away stuff that might be important.
So that, I, I don't know, I don't want to dig through trash guys.
I don't know.
I'm so, do I just trust her?
And not look through that?
Like, do I just, I don't know.
Maybe, maybe, you know, if it gets thrown away, that's just life telling me it might not have been that important.
I, I, I, I just, I don't know.
If, if, if it's, I still have the trash bag.
Cause she's like, oh, I'll throw away, I can take away your garbage too.
Um, but then I said no, because, um, um, I said no, because like, you have, she has to like, go to like, the, the garbage room is locked with my key.
Like, you have to have my key and fob to like, unlock the garbage door.
So I was like, oh, it's such a hassle for you to come back downstairs and then come back upstairs, back and forth.
Like, she couldn't just like, you know, throw it away and just leave.
She has to like, come back upstairs to give me back my key and everything.
So I was like, oh, now it's fine.
I'll just throw it away on my own time.
And along with the, um, um, along with like, uh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, the cardboard boxes she disassembled.
So I was just like, ah, now it's fine.
Next thing, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Our friends forgot important things to run away by cleaning people.
I don't know if I risk it.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know what's surprising?
Okay, so...
Oh my gosh, I don't want to dig through trash.
I don't know what she's... I don't know.
I don't want to dig through it.
Anyway, um...
Oh fuck, I lost my train of thought.
I'm so tired.
You know, like, when you're more tired, you're more forgetful.
I lost my train of thought.
Fuck, oh, what was I on?
What was I talking about, guys, before that?
Zyka, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for being here after all these years.
You being competitive gamer makes me so happy.
Today is my birthday!
I wish you a happy memory throughout the journey along with all the Horseоздings here.
Happy Birthday, Zyko.
Happy Birthday to you.
Happy Birthday dear Zyko.
Yeah!
Happy Birthday.
Okay, also, um...
I can't.
I can't see this for, like...
I... I can't.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me, like be here.
Okay, there you go.
Sorry.
I just can't see...
I'm not...
It was bothering me a lot.
So I'll lower the music a little bit.
What was I on before I was talking about garbage?
Fuck, okay.
Sorry, guys.
I need you guys to remind me.
I'm gonna get gamer subs after this tangent.
After the cleaning tangent.
Just so my brain can start remembering things again.
The new system?
Oh, like how she rearranged everything.
Okay, something about...
Oh my god, it was something important.
Fuck, oh my god.
Something important about the cleaning.
Give me a sec, guys.
I need to reboot my brain again.
What was it?
Oh,
fuck.
Okay, so she wanted to do the cleaning.
She was drinking through the trash to find stuff.
I don't want to do it because I know I should.
I know I should because I don't know if she like...
I'm just worried.
Oh yeah, she like...
Oh yeah, okay, I remember.
Okay, so...
Like she even like...
So...
I can't spoil what it is.
But like...
I got sent a package from...
Uh...
My new distributor.
For like...
New merch and stuff.
Um...
But this was a while ago.
I got sent about it for like...
Two months ago.
But it was still in my room.
And then like...
They wanted...
Like one or two months ago.
And it was like...
They wanted my opinion on like stuff.
Because they sent me the sample.
And it was been in my room.
Like the box that's been in my room.
And then she even took that box.
Because I...
I like gave her a pile of boxes.
To disassemble.
I gave her like a pile...
No, it's still Gamersupps.
Gamersupps is my new distributor.
Um...
But...
Uh...
They're not working as Gamersupps.
They're just acting as my distributor.
So they're not...
It's not like it's like under the Gamersupp website.
They're like...
Acting as a distributor for me.
That's why I don't say Gamersupps.
I just say distributor.
Um...
Anyway.
They're like acting independently away...
Not as Gamersupps.
For my...
For my merch.
Um...
Anyway.
What I was saying was that...
Uh...
So like...
I had that box there.
With the product that was there.
Like the merch.
Whatever it is.
I can't say what it is.
Because they'll spoil it.
Um...
But anyway.
I had a pile of boxes for her to disassemble in the kitchen.
But while she was cleaning my office.
She like...
Took that box.
And like...
Put it in the disassemble area too.
She like disassemb...
She like...
With her own free will.
Like...
Disassembled that box.
And like...
Like...
Put the merch stuff.
And rearrange that merch stuff.
In a different location.
So she went like...
Above and beyond.
Because my instructions were like...
You see that pile?
Just disassemble all of that pile.
You know?
Like I was...
But...
No.
I did tell her to like...
Do the disassembling...
In my office.
And then...
And then she...
So you know I have like a bunch of boxes...
That I haven't unpacked yet...
Since I moved in here.
So you know...
She saw all those boxes...
Because it's like a huge pile of them...
On the side of the wall in my living room.
And she saw those boxes...
And she's like...
Oh yeah I saw all of that.
Do you want me to unpack those for you too?
And I said no.
Because I...
Because I was like...
If she does that...
I don't know how long she'll be here for.
I have no idea how long she was gonna be there for.
And also like...
I'm moving soon?
Maybe.
Or I stay here a little longer.
I don't know.
But my lease is almost up.
And I'm keeping those boxes packed up.
So I can keep them packed up...
In my next place.
That I'm moving to.
It's gonna stay packed up.
Until I finally own a house.
Or some shit.
I don't know.
Whenever I'm unpacking that...
Giant pile of mess.
Anyway.
So yeah.
So like...
And then like...
Okay and I had some like...
And I told her.
She was like...
Can I make your bed too?
Because obviously you know...
I just woke up.
And the bed was just like...
A fucking hazard.
A hazard already.
And then I was like...
No no.
It's okay.
And then she still made my bed.
She's like...
Are you sure?
And I was like...
Yeah yeah.
I'm sure.
Then like you know...
The office is clean.
So I went back to the office to do some work stuff.
And then...
I went back to my bedroom.
And then she still...
She made my bed.
I was like...
So surprised.
Oh you don't have to.
I said you don't have to.
And she still did it.
I think she was like...
You know...
Worried for me.
I don't know.
She might have been like...
Concerned about my lifestyle.
Or something.
Because like...
I had to...
Because I was very surprised with...
With how...
With what she...
With everything in general.
And so...
Thank you.
You are a baby.
Oh yeah.
But the funniest shit is that...
So she put...
So like...
Dad has like wet food.
Because of his kidneys issues.
So like he has like a specialized...
Like wet food for his diet.
And then so...
What like...
Like...
He found her weakness.
Like not...
So not her weakness.
He found a weak point.
Like...
Where we all let our guard down.
She like put the wet...
The dog food.
Because I can only...
It was a big can of food.
So I can only feed it like...
I can only feed like...
Half a can...
Per meal.
So obviously I have to keep the can open.
For like dinner time.
And then...
She was cleaning the...
Desk.
And then she put the can...
On the ground.
And that fucker...
Like...
Bolted.
He's like...
This is my chance!
And he like...
Bolted.
And he's like...
And then stuck his entire face...
Into the can.
He's like...
No, I can't reseal it.
Because it's a fucking can.
I just threw like...
Look, it's like...
Those pop cans.
Like it's not a can opener.
It's like those like...
You know, like a Coke can.
You go...
Like that.
So like...
She put the can...
On the ground.
And he's like...
And his entire nose...
His entire fucking face...
Was just like...
In the can like...
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
And luckily...
His nose wasn't long enough...
To eat the entire thing.
Thank fucking god.
Just...
Thank god.
His nose...
Okay, I'll illustrate...
What I saw...
Today.
Alright.
I'll illustrate for you guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me draw this.
And then like...
This is his face.
And then he was just like...
You don't even see the eyes.
That's how fucked up it was.
Like...
Because he was in so deep.
Okay, here.
And then he's like...
Yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum.
And yeah.
I like instantly went over.
Like I don't know how much he fucking was able to eat from that can.
But I instantly went over and like...
Grab...
Grab the rest of it away from him.
Before he could finish his fucking dinner.
Because I am not opening another can.
I have a system.
If I...
If I open another can, he ruins the system.
And then I'll have to keep that half a can the next day every time.
Alright.
So this is what he looked like.
Basically.
Like...
He was like...
But yeah.
Like...
You can't even...
Like I...
You don't even see the eyes.
No, it's like a Coke can.
So like...
It's like those type of cans.
So he can't like...
He can't like hurt himself because there's no edges.
It's like the pot...
It's like a popping open type of Coke can type shit.
So it's not like I'm using a can opener.
So there's no like actual sharp edges.
But yeah.
No.
He couldn't even...
Thank God it was a tall can.
So like...
He couldn't get to the end of it.
Because...
And there was still some remaining dog food in there.
So thank God.
Um...
You activated the cleaner's motherly instinct.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
This girl needs help.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Damn, girl.
You live like this.
But ironically...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're still a peak artist.
Thank you for the super chat, Anton.
Thank you.
But yeah.
But yeah, that's basically how the day's been.
I was literally just sitting there.
Like, I guess I... when she was done with the office, I went to do some work stuff.
To do some work stuff to, you know, pass the time.
You know, to pass the time and stuff like that.
Uh... what else can I talk about?
About the cleaner?
Uh... I mean, my cleaner did move my monitors around.
And, like, that, like, fucked with me a little bit.
Because, like... like, I get... I'm very anal about my monitor position.
So, like, I spent, like... I just spent, like, 15 minutes just trying to, like...
Uh... rearrange my monitor to, like, be similar to what it was before.
Um... I have no idea how... like, I don't know.
Like, I get so anal about that shit.
Because, you know, like, when they move it just a little bit...
And everything just feels off.
Like...
That's how I feel.
Uh, JL!
Thank you to the super chat!
Thank you!
Uh...
But, yeah, she was, like... she was a really nice cleaner.
Um... I literally... Jim Lee did not expect the amount of effort she put through...
She put in for the day.
I gave her a $20 tip.
Because, like...
Um... usually...
Because I usually don't...
Don't...
Have small bills on me.
Um...
I usually don't have small bills on me or anything.
Uh...
But I did have a $20 lying around on the table.
So, I was like, you know what?
You know, she deserves...
She deserves this tip.
And it wasn't even, like...
It was, like, $180 for four hours.
And honestly, like, with the amount...
For, like...
Um...
Per month.
Usually...
Usually my...
Uh...
Cleaning bill per month is, like, $140 for three hours.
Like, for three hours.
And it's, like, once a month.
Um...
But this time, she, you know, she stayed for an extra hour.
Because it's usually...
It's, like, three...
They...
My older...
Other cleaning takes, like, three hours.
Um...
And Canadian, by the way.
I think it's, like...
It's usually...
Canadian...
And it's Canadian dollars.
So, it's a lot cheaper than American.
But I felt like it was such a good deal.
And, you know, she did a lot.
And, um, and... No, the reason why I don't carry small bills is because I just use card.
I... And, like, all my big bills were from, like, Licey.
Were from red pocket money.
So, like, I was, like, you know, I have, like, a collection of, like, red pocket money in my wallet that I got.
Like, and I just, you know, and they're all, like, big bills.
And that's, like, literally, um, why I have even big bill money.
And, you know, I...
I have... I just keep... I don't use them.
I don't use my... I don't use, like, actual, like, paper money.
Um, so I just keep it in my wallet for, like, emergencies.
Like, uh, so I keep, like, like, four or five red pockets in my wallet for, like, emergencies in case I do need paper money.
Um, so I mostly just use card for, like, I always just use card for everything or Apple Pay.
Like, legitimately just poop.
Like, it's just so convenient.
I... there's no reason.
It's not like I... it's not like I, like, am at a gas station and then my card get fucking swiped by a card eater or something.
Like, I'm not at a gas station.
I'm at a fucking restaurant.
So I'm just gonna boop and then that's it.
Um, most of the time I spend money...
It's just on, like, you know, a reputable store that I think won't steal my information.
So...
I assume that I am at a place that doesn't have a...
have a fucking fake card insert that's gonna steal my money.
Like, that's what I hope I'm at.
So that's why I mostly just use...
um, just use my card and not cash money.
Um, anyway.
I will be right back, guys.
Also, before I be right...
because I need to get gamer stuff because I am so tired.
My brain is taking 20 years to, like, boot up right now and to think.
Uh, because of how tired I am at the moment.
Uh, Gumbetto!
But before I go, Gumbetto, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, hi, Doki.
Today is my birthday!
Thank you for bringing so much laughter to my life!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Gumbetto.
Yeah!
Yay!
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm gonna get some gamer subs real quick.
Because I am tired.
Sorry, I need to...
I, I, like, lowered the volume, but forgot what the volume was.
So here's, like, random dad for...
Alright, I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
I have to...
Ugh!
Gamer subs.
So, I hope I can finish the game this week.
Because I did say on street...
On my schedule that I am finishing the game this week.
So, yeah.
I know I did say I was gonna give you guys picture updates for, like...
All the stuff.
Like, dad updates and all that shit.
I know I...
I was like, oh, I'm gonna give you picture updates of a bunch of things.
I honestly forgot what I was supposed to show you guys.
But we're many, crush.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Seiji, thank you for the super chat.
Welcome back.
I...
I forgot what...
I remember I was like...
Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna show you guys pictures and stuff.
But I legitimately forgot, like, what pictures are...
Oh, yeah!
Okay.
Let me write it down.
I didn't write it down, guys.
So, that was the issue.
Usually, I write stuff down when I was like...
I'm gonna show this to stream.
Okay.
Sand stuff.
Uh, dad pictures.
And...
What was it?
Uh...
Uh, the t-shirt.
Okay, the t-shirt.
Alright.
Alright, okay.
Yeah, because I was like, oh yeah, I'll show you guys.
Um, I'll show it to you guys during, like, the Mario month, but, like, I didn't have time.
I didn't have time to gather everything.
I've been so busy.
I've been so busy every day.
Oh my gosh.
Like, if I'm not sleeping, I'm working lately.
Hmm.
You're in the game volume down?
Yeah, no problem.
Uh, let me see.
Uh, there we go.
Alright, is that better, guys?
I turned the volume down a little bit.
Um, what flavor don't you wanna know?
He-he.
I'll never tell.
So, make you guys buy multiple Gamersub tubs using my code.
Bite Size!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Papa Smerd.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
What percentage of your cardboard box stash was due to laziness?
How much was due to noodle arms?
It can be both.
Why not both?
I'm a cleaner.
Who's gonna be here anyway?
So, like, why don't I just ask her to help me?
She's getting paid!
It's not like she's doing it for free!
Look, the thing is, if I had to do it, I'd be doing it for free, okay?
That's the issue.
But since she's here, she's getting paid anyway.
So, why should I do something that would have been free for myself?
Like, I don't pay myself.
You guys pay me.
This entire ca- This entire castle is one giant dungeon!
Make sure you're well stocked!
And healed!
And don't forget to take breaks!
Okay, I heard this is, like, a really long one, too.
Um, bro, Mario, you gotta come when you're not beating up my boss.
Actually pretty chill most of the time.
I have some extra healing supplies if you let me heal!
Okay.
Hey, hey, hey!
Isn't it hot, hot, hot?
You know what else is hot, hot, hot?
Sell, sell, sell!
So why don't you...
Bye, bye, bye!
Alright, do they have actual good hats?
No, I already have...
I forgot we paid you!
Santina, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, Matty, thank you for the super chat!
Can I pay you ten bucks to put away the next box?
You guys!
Thank you for the super chat, Matty!
Thank you, thank you!
I'll think about it.
Oh, yeah, Max Zero!
Alright.
Let's see.
Current room.
One door to first floor.
What?
What does that mean?
Okay, so there's that entrance.
And then...
Current room.
Type to...
Oh, my God.
I'm already so confused.
Current room.
Okay, this is one, two.
Alright.
Uh...
Oh, I want to take a picture.
Yeah.
Yay!
Okay, so this entire area is just a maze.
Okay, thank God.
Because I was, like, thinking.
I was, like...
Am I going to be able to complete the skiing today?
And I was, like...
No, Doki.
If it's a maze...
You're going to spend your whole life in that one maze.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, this is neat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Can you do a favor and pick either violet, pink, or green?
Uh...
Violet.
Or Bowser may be evil.
Leo's the hardest of ragers I have ever seen.
Comment suggested to Bowser an open cause of catching.
And cannot let go of that idea for the rest of the castle.
All right, I guess...
Can I go through the main door?
Okay, no.
Okay, I'll just go through...
You know what?
I'll go through this one.
I'll go to the second floor first.
Can't be that bad.
Okay.
Bite me.
I need to level up.
You're in a war...
For a world of pain.
You got the...
Yeah, but I want to know if there's any mons I haven't caught yet.
Is it, like, used up now?
Is, like, my repel active...
What the...
I keep forgetting your...
I keep forgetting your hair.
I was like...
What are you doing?
Rice, get back in there.
Smug!
Death, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Is the...
Is the infinite repel, like, on right now?
Or, like, do I have to activate it?
Because I do want to...
Yeah, Rice is not meant to fight.
They're just there to look pretty.
Okay, so I can look around and see if I have any I need to catch first.
Oh shit, no, that's a fire.
All right.
Fuck.
Okay, that's awkward.
You're just there to look pretty on my team.
You're like the...
You have pretty privilege.
Okay, that's good.
Okay.
Let's get that...
Uh, it did that much damage.
You're just like a panda.
Pandas would have been extinct if...
They weren't so cute.
Nice.
Okay.
Like, you basically got in via sheer nepotism because of pretty privilege.
All right.
Let's see.
Dad back up here.
True.
You told us already multiple times?
Yes!
Because it's...
I need to make a statement!
Oh shit.
That's not the cap I wanted to throw.
All right.
Oh, it's the wix.
Oh, never mind.
I'm gonna stay winning, baby.
I don't hate pandas.
I just think that...
The reason why they're hopeless right now...
The reason why...
They can't do anything for themselves...
Is that we might have, like...
Made them like that and kept it...
Okay.
Nice.
Yay!
All right.
Who wants to be a hammer, bro?
Alana, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Welcome, everybody.
Apparently, like...
Pandas can actually eat something else other than bamboo...
But they just choose not to.
Like, how fucking stupid...
All right.
A bro that can adapt to almost any combat situation...
With its knowledge of different projectiles.
A group of it is called a frat.
And it's very annoying.
All right.
I mean...
Do you really know?
Like...
Them eating bamboo is literally just a choice.
They can, like, actually...
Like, stomachs can actually eat anything else.
It's like when koalas...
Can try and eat anything else...
But then they just choose to be high.
They just choose to be high all the time.
All right.
Okay, lost.
I'll give you...
I'll give you a hammer, bro.
Okay, lost.
Lost.
Goon.
All right.
Nice.
What's that?
Can I open that door?
Oh, I don't have to put out trooper.
Oh, my God.
I'm, like, kidnapping all his minions.
Like, are they...
I don't know if I'm...
Yay!
My prisoner of war.
For legal reasons...
That's a joke, guys.
That's a joke.
A flying turtle with angel-like wings...
Is often enlisted as a common foot soldier.
It follows a marching pattern.
Determined by the color of its shell.
All right.
Who wants to be my prisoner?
It was not a joke.
He...
He still has a family.
Just...
He can't see them anymore.
That's different.
Like...
He just can't see his family.
He lives in my box for the rest of his life.
Uh, Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You and Panda share a lot of qualities.
Like poor diet.
Unable to clean after yourself.
And can't build anything.
Yes.
And you guys enabled me.
That's right.
That's my pretty privilege.
And you're the suit keepers.
That are making sure I don't go extinct.
That's right.
I'm owning my pretty privilege.
I...
I won't leave the problem.
Okay.
All right.
Who wants to be my prisoner of war?
Who...
Okay.
Wait.
DJ, do you have...
Does DJ have one already?
DJ...
Goon.
All right.
It's fine.
I'll rename it if he does.
Here's the baboose.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat, Mehdi.
Wait.
How would he...
Shoot that?
What?
It says...
It's whole as a bullet.
But how would it...
Shoot it?
I don't know.
I don't fucking...
Wait.
Actually, let me read this.
Whoops.
Looking at Doki like Oppenheim.
We...
We created this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Johnny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
We're enabling her.
We're the reason she survives off of...
I am a gamer sub to take out.
Look.
It's an endless...
It's an endless circle.
Guys.
And I feed you.
You feed me.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
It's fine.
I got away safely.
Okay.
I think Dad can take him on.
Like, he might be like...
At...
At the brink of death.
But like...
I believe in him.
As long as he's faster.
He is faster, right?
As long...
As long as you're faster.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Thank God.
We made it.
Let's go gambling.
Gambling.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's an Uber Eats meal down into the enclosure.
Yeah.
I did it.
Oh, but he like blocked my only fucking...
Okay.
I need to go back and heal though.
Oh, I don't have a Goomba stack.
Oh my God.
Nice.
Okay.
I can basically catch all the ones that I haven't got.
Alright.
Who wants to be this pathetic...
Uh...
Pathetic stack of enemies.
Like, it's sad.
It's like, yeah.
One Goomba is sad.
But now there's like five of you.
Now it's just five sad people together.
I'm pathetic.
That's me.
Like, it doesn't change anything.
All I have to do is just step one.
Alright.
Nice.
A stack of Goombas.
They join forces like this to impress mates.
But not without fighting over.
Which gets...
What gets to be on...
What?
Which one gets to be on top?
And...
What?
Wouldn't...
Okay.
But like...
But...
Wouldn't the person at the bottom have the most fun?
Wouldn't you...
Wouldn't you want to be at...
I don't understand.
Why would you want to be at the top?
What do you get out of it?
If you squint really hard, you might be able to see her.
Like, does he look like his ass?
Like, I'm just saying...
Like, what does he get out of it?
By being at the top?
But it's to impress mates.
They're trying to be like, you know...
All the short kings.
All the short kings get together and be like...
If we all like climb on top of each other...
And wear a very, very long coat...
Then like...
Then the ladies won't swipe left on us.
Like...
I'm the top.
That's me.
Why should I think it was a super chat that you're thinking?
Unless like...
No, don't think about it like that.
No, I shouldn't finish the question.
All right.
Okay, I'll choose four dragons...
To be the Goomba stack.
And you guys can decide who's on top.
All right.
Unless...
Unless, you know...
You know...
The top part does get all the action.
Like...
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nextie, thank you for the super chat.
Who wants to be...
Okay.
Who wants to be the bottom?
Who...
All right.
Who wants...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I saw...
Kepan wants to be...
Okay.
We need two more.
Look, there's not enough...
Oh, I can't even.
Okay.
All right.
There's like not enough room.
I just realized.
All right.
You're just...
You just get initials, guys.
There's not enough room.
Um...
H...
K...
You know who you are.
H...
K...
Uh...
You guys each get one letter.
G...
For...
Grumple.
And then one more letter, guys.
H...
K...
G...
All right.
A.
I don't know...
Wait.
Can we make a name?
Oh, wait.
Let's see.
We can make a name out of this.
K...
H...
A...
G...
K...
A...
H...
G...
Okay.
H...
A...
Hag?
H...
A...
Hag...
K...
Okay.
Goood.
You guys can decide who's the top and who's the bottom.
Oh, Kingdom Hearts Hag?
Yeah, let's do that, actually.
Wait.
That's actually good.
He...
I like that.
Kingdom Hearts Hag.
Okay.
All right.
Goon.
Here we go.
Tagoon.
All right.
You guys figure out who's the top and who's the bottom.
I need to heal myself real quick.
All right.
Let's go back in.
Bum.
Can I go...
Can I swim through lava?
Oh, my God.
Stop!
All you do is just die anyway.
Let me go.
Leave.
Leave me.
Oh, my God.
That's it.
I'm going to sit on him.
I'm angry now.
Get over here.
I don't think I actually need the XP.
I mean, like...
I feel like my guy's already...
Dad's already overpowered as hell.
Hmm.
Yay!
Okay.
Can I...
No, I can't.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Wait, what's...
Did I miss something over there?
No.
Bum.
Wait, what?
Okay.
So, I can't do anything here.
So, I have to leave here anyway.
All right.
We go this way.
We're at this room now.
God, this place is so confusing already.
I...
I'm already so...
How is he so slow?
Like...
What?
Okay, I need to know what's...
What's his speed.
I...
I need to know.
I need to know what the fuck is the speed.
All right.
Sit on him.
Because he...
They won't leave me alone.
It's almost like it's a maze, Joki.
Wow.
It's very maze-like, isn't it?
All right.
What's your speed?
Like, how bad is it?
It's not even that bad.
Oh my god.
My special defense.
Oh.
I mean, like...
Yoshi has less speed.
Okay, but he is less speed.
Oh my god.
He's so fucking buffed up.
And then...
The other guy is just average.
Oh, you guys can't see it?
Oh.
Okay.
There.
It's like...
It is his weakest stat.
Oh my god.
My attack is so fucking crazy.
No wonder I'm one-shotting everything.
Mother.
All right.
Get over here.
You're not going anywhere, Mario.
Yeah, that is pretty fucking strong.
I mean, look at...
Okay, look.
There's a reason why he's so slow.
Okay, look at him, guys.
He's fucking built like a unit right now.
It's not his fault.
And he's just big boned, okay?
He's big boned.
It's just all muscle.
I swear to god.
It's all muscle, guys.
All right.
Sit.
Yeah.
Big boy.
Big boy making big plans.
Yarrg.
Okay.
I'll just throw him.
Throw him!
Throw him back into the lava where he belongs.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
That doesn't do that much damage.
Yeah!
Easy.
Unless we only use our captures.
All right.
Oh my gosh, I'm so lost.
I'm here doing a safety audit.
And on the castle, I can stay with almost certainty that's too hot and too scary.
Okay, clearly I should go this way, right?
Okay.
I already have him.
Guys, have I got all the captures in this castle?
Or like, is there some that...
Is there anyone that I haven't got yet?
All these doors don't make moving around the castle any easier.
Whoever designed this really must be fun and want to see everyone suffer.
Oh, okay.
He doesn't want to fight me.
That's good.
They're spread across different rooms?
Oh, okay.
So there's some that I have yet to see.
All right.
Okay, I'm back here.
Okay, that's not...
That's not it.
Oh, boy.
I can't wait to start my journey in the cat challenge.
I hope I can get all power...
Eight power stars before anyone else's.
Hey, Mario.
How many do you have?
You have seven above to get your eighth?
Wow.
That's fantastic.
Thanks for telling me.
I'm going to quit before I get too infested.
Good for you.
Know your place, little guy.
There's a reason why you don't have a name and I do.
Some people were just born to not be special.
Just like you, little man.
Whoa.
What?
Bro.
Some people were just meant to be an NPC in your story.
Oh, so rude.
Did I scare you?
Please just let him have this one.
Not even good enough to be my prisoner.
Under a war.
So sad.
Inspirational words.
By Toki.
Alright.
Nice.
I have no small bills.
Bye.
Oh, there he is.
Wait.
Why did he not send this one out?
Oh, wait.
No.
He is just going to duplicate me.
Okay.
That is fine.
I will just throw him.
Get out of here.
That is right.
You think you can duplicate me?
You will never be as good as the original.
Alright.
Where do I go?
There is another door there.
Don't get cocky because you have seven power stars.
I will still defeat you.
Who is...
Who is we?
I only have one son.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I feel like...
A T-Rex might be bigger than...
I don't know why I didn't think...
I don't know why I didn't think he's like...
Smaller...
Than a fucking bomb.
Okay.
That's fine.
I can still throw you.
Yay!
I'm sure I'm missing like...
A shitload of mines too.
Okay.
This looks new.
Guys.
This looks new, guys.
You have been stopped by Corporal Par...
Parablong.
Prepare to be beaten, silly.
Okay.
That's fine.
See, this is why I have to over...
I have to level up so...
Dad so much.
Because he's so fucking slow.
If he's like...
You know...
If he's 20 levels higher than everybody else...
Eventually he'll be faster.
Right?
Eventually.
Oh shit.
Never mind.
Goodbye.
Bye, dad.
True.
Oh, now he's even faster.
Wow.
Okay.
He's already dead.
I guess.
Think.
My son has an actual rock move, right?
Because you're ground.
Okay.
This should be it.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Never mind.
Clearly I don't know.
Oh, I...
Sorry.
I don't remember my type matchups again.
I...
Sorry.
I forgot my type matchups again.
Alright.
There you go.
I...
I don't know.
They're both made of rocks.
I don't understand.
Both of them are made of rocks.
They both...
It's all Earth Element.
It's like air, water, fire, Earth.
It's not air, water, fire, ground.
Air, water, fire, rock.
Okay.
Meter match.
This should work.
Well, there should be.
They should just get rid of ground and rock.
Fuck type system.
I want my Earth mood.
Are you having a stroke?
Okay, hammer, bro.
Hammer, bro.
Okay.
Surely dragon will work, right?
Go.
Dragoon?
I love the question mark.
Alright.
Let's see.
Fuck you.
Just swing your tail.
Swing that tail.
Oh my god.
You're so fucking weak.
Alright.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
We have two disappointments on this team.
Or not.
We have two disappointments in this battle.
Okay, nice.
Yay!
Okay, so...
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Whoops.
I got a little greedy.
Go, stick bug.
Shiny versus shiny.
Okay, I wanted to get the bullet key.
I don't know what this is.
Oh, it's a key item.
Oh!
That's for that door from earlier.
Okay.
Oh, there's a mecha koopa.
Nice.
I needed that.
I don't have one.
Alright, who wants to be a mecha koopa?
Oh, never mind.
Not yet.
Get stick bug.
Bye, stick bug.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Come on.
Yay!
A terrible toy that was created by the most manacle of men.
It's wound up with a key on its back.
It can start itself.
This is Bowser Jr.'s favorite toy.
Wait, does he have sentience then?
Alright.
Who wants to be mecha koopa, guys?
Who wants to be a toy?
Whose only purpose is to die.
Alright, rag.
Rag.
Goon.
There you go.
Ragoon.
Goddammit.
Okay.
I must be close to catching all the...
stuff, right?
In these rooms?
Okay, I should really...
Fuck.
Whoops.
Please beat us on TM.
You're not using them anyway.
Yabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You don't know that.
What if at the end of the Bowser fight...
Like...
It's like my moment to shine.
Oops.
Sorry, Stickbug.
I wasn't...
Whoops.
Alright.
Goodbye, Stickbug.
Oh, nice!
Okay, it did nothing.
I wasn't paying attention.
So I was like, oops.
Okay, we need to go back.
So I can...
I can use...
I can heal Dad.
Thank God, Stickbug lived.
And he's so fucking fast.
So I can, like, run away from everything.
It's right...
Yeah?
Yeah.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
Can I use an...
Can I just...
Oh, I could just TP.
I could just use my warp pipe.
You're right.
I forgot about my warp pipe.
Alright, next time I'll just warp pipe out.
I forgot I have other items in my inventory.
Alright.
Goodbye, Mecha Koopa.
Hello, fight me.
I need your XP.
So Dad won't be slow as fuck.
Superfly?
The fuck?
What's that?
Where is he from?
I've never seen that guy before.
Oh, he hurt himself.
For what reason?
I don't think I'm smart enough to understand this guy's mind.
I'm just like...
We'll never understand what goes on in that mind.
Like, what the fuck?
Why did he do that?
His goals are beyond your comprehension.
Oh, Final Gambit.
What's that?
Use your fangs to damage a foe equal to its HP.
Oh, so like, it does max.
Wait, why do that?
When I can just use explosion.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
That's just explosion.
With more steps.
Explosion, but different.
Alright, get out of here.
Go find your girl.
Short kings.
I believe in them.
Okay.
Alright, we go that way.
There's a door here.
Oh!
Oh, no, I already have one.
Alright, where am I?
I can't even go anywhere here.
What the fuck is the point of that room?
That room was so fucking big.
Okay, we go down here.
Wait, is there...
I didn't go upstairs.
Maybe there's something upstairs.
Oh, yeah, there is.
Nice.
Oh, it was just a hat.
We can't go through here?
No.
Okay, I need to find a button for here.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Okay, must have got all of them now, right?
Oh, my God.
That's it.
I'm angry.
Okay, never mind.
Apparently...
He knew my bluff.
I...
He saw my bluff.
Alright, I'm warping out.
Wait, where am I?
Where do I...
Where am I?
Where do I live here?
Alright, that's Daisy Cruiser.
Cloud Cap.
Shiny Galaxy.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, right here.
Okay, I'll just TP back.
Alright, heal me.
And then...
Where was the door again?
Was it here?
Oh, no.
It was at the first floor.
I remember.
There it is.
See, guys?
I can beat mazes.
Not as it seems in Lord Bowser's castle.
What wears like this is that you can poke out of...
Or actually tunnels.
Tunnels?
Oh.
How does this work?
I can figure this out.
Guys, I can figure this out.
Give me a sec.
Okay, let me reset this real quick.
Let me...
Okay, I got...
Okay, give me a sec.
I can figure this out.
Guys, I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
Okay.
I can figure this out.
Yeah!
Okay, give me a sec.
Wait a minute.
But not by your hammer?
Oh!
Wait, I can reset this here, right?
Okay.
Okay, now we clear the path for the bullet.
It was a long game, guys.
Okay.
I can figure this out.
Oh, that's awkward.
Guys, it's a long, long game.
I'm tired.
I'm so tired of all these fucking guys who want to be prisoners.
Okay, there you go.
I need, like...
I need no interruptions.
Okay, this time.
Okay.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm thinking.
Oh.
Give me a sec, guys.
Um.
Oh, it could have threw a cannon?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I told you.
Look at that.
I'm so smart.
I'm so fucking smart.
Oh, my God.
I'm actually a genius.
I should get, like, those...
You know, like, those, like, special degrees?
You know those universities that give you, like, specialized degrees?
You don't have to do anything.
You just gotta be famous and then you earn one.
I deserve one of those.
Privileged degrees.
Yeah.
I should get an honorary degree.
I wonder if, like, you can actually do anything with it.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even read.
I was like, why didn't that work?
I forgot he's also fire.
I wonder if you can actually, like, do anything with those degrees.
Like, if you get one from, like, a university that specializes in, like, doctorate degrees.
Or, like, that specializes in, like, making doctors.
And then, like, you know, you just flash...
You're like, don't worry, guys.
I'm a doctor.
And then you flash a degree real quick.
But you don't, like, let them see what that says honorary degree.
And be like, no, guys.
It's Dr. Doki to you.
Yeah, but then they'll be like, oh, you see a degree that's from Harvard.
And he's like, don't worry, guys.
Wait, no.
Harvard's for law.
Okay, yeah.
Sorry.
Harvard's for law.
That's not for doctorate.
I'm trying to remember which school is for doctors.
And business, too.
Yeah, but isn't it mostly for, like, law?
They're mostly specialized in law.
And business.
I mean, it's still Harvard, I guess.
Harvard is still Harvard.
You're right.
I feel like I could just be like, yeah, guys.
I went to Harvard.
And then you just flash the honor degree.
I don't know if you can, like, Photoshop a Harvard degree.
And just change your name.
Like, how would people...
Okay, but, like...
Okay, but if you're, like, applying for, like, not, like, you know, the toppest position in, like...
Isn't that...
Yeah, if you get caught...
I'm saying, okay.
Obviously, you know...
If you try to be, like, a big lawyer in a big lawyer company...
Like, obviously, they'll check on your databases.
Because, like, some...
Some, like, law firms actually are, like...
They only hire Harvard students and stuff.
Okay, you should not have sat on that.
But...
But, like...
Like, if...
Like, but, like, if you try to go for a job for, like, you know, a small town...
A small town law firm...
And then they're, like...
Oh, why did you want to work here?
Like, you could have any...
And you're, like...
Oh, I just want to...
I just want...
I just want to...
You know...
Relax from this big city.
Like...
I just...
I just want to relax from the big city.
Okay.
For legal reasons...
Guys, for legal reasons...
It's a joke.
For legal reasons...
This is a joke, guys.
I would never commit fraud.
It's just a hee-ha-ha, hee-ha-ha moment.
It's just a joke, guys.
It's just a joke.
But, like, I'm just wondering.
I'm pretty sure somebody has done it.
There's no way.
There's no way, like...
Like, someone hasn't done something like that.
Wait, what?
What did I open?
I don't even know what I opened.
Wait, did it work?
Did it work?
Yeah, but, like...
A small town... a small-time firm in...
Okay, I'm gonna use the rappel.
A small-town firm in, like, not a big city?
Like, they won't check around.
Like, how would they check?
If your degree is actually from Harvard.
Harvard, they don't have the power for that.
Oh, I don't have a wand.
Oh, I turned it off!
They call Harvard.
Just be like, oh, my family was just tired of the big city.
But, like, they don't know you have no family.
You'd be like, the wife and kids.
They were just...
They just wanted to be closer to their parents.
So, that's why I'm here.
I...
A sentient slab of payment is stubborn and refuses to forget grudges.
Now, it's just sad!
It's sort of special...
Social dominance is determined by the number of cracks on its back.
Like, okay.
I know.
So, then, you don't...
You don't Photoshop a Harvard degree.
You Photoshop a tier below Harvard.
Like, brown or something.
Like, I don't know.
Um, Stanford or something.
Like,
I don't know.
Um, Stanford or something.
Oh, stop taking...
Don't you resist the temptation.
Alright.
Uh, Cardi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, you want to be a womp?
Alright, Cardi.
Cardi...
Goon.
Alright, I didn't even realize I turned it off.
I thought I turned it on.
Gotta remember how to get back, though.
And it's like, here?
I'm pretty sure I caught every...
Oh, no!
There's a thomp!
Oh, my God.
Just as I said that.
A thomp appeared.
He's like, you caught my brother.
I'm here for revenge.
That's why you have to end all bloodline.
So there's never...
So they can't do any revenge.
That's the Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is all hype.
Guys, for legal reasons, do not try anything I'm saying.
If you get caught, and you're like, oh, I watched a Jokey Bird stream.
And, like, she inspired me to do it.
For legal reasons, you cannot say that it was because of me.
Disclaimer, because it was a joke.
A spiked slab of concrete.
With the ability to have...
It's like when someone was like...
When someone goes like, no homo.
You know?
This is my version.
For legal reasons, this is a joke.
So it doesn't count, guys.
It doesn't...
Legally, I am exempt from any fraud charges.
In medieval times, it guarded...
No crime-o.
Yeah.
No fraud-o.
No fraud-o, guys.
In medieval times, it guarded the entrances to castles occupied by powerful tyrants.
All right.
Who wants to be thromphed?
And be married to...
Whomp.
Tiny?
All right.
Tiny.
I think it's above average.
Don't worry.
If you squint hard enough.
Tiny ghoul.
No, they're married.
I have to do it again?
All right.
Stop thinking for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why go through all the effort when everyone knows the easiest way to get a fake degree from Harvard is to donate an undisclosed amount of money in them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, but like...
What if you don't have millions of dollars, guys?
I'm for the people.
Wait, do I have to turn it?
I'm so confused.
Oh no, there's...
It's off over there.
Wait, how do I get there?
Oh!
Wait, how the fuck do I get there?
Oh my...
I'm so lost.
It's like it's a maze or some shit.
Okay, let's just use the e-guide.
All right.
Oh, it's neat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maybe here?
No.
Oh yeah, it is here.
Okay, nice.
Oh, now I can use lava.
All right.
I can use lava now, guys.
It's okay.
The world is safe.
Toki's lawyer found dead from alcohol poisoning.
Yabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh wait, I can fish in here.
Maybe I'll get a blog.
Yeah!
I've got the blog.
I'm not a doctor.
It's just my legal name.
That's so smart.
You can have your first name be Doctor.
Just legally...
You can legally change your name to anything.
And just legally change your first name to Doctor.
So then you can...
And then your last name to be like your first name.
Oh, I can't catch it because he like flew away, I guess.
Wait, what did he do?
It's like Doctor Spaceman.
You know that.
I'd be like, Oh yeah, my name is Doctor Doki.
And then it'd be like, Wow, you're a doctor?
And then you just don't say anything.
Because it's not lying if you omit information.
You're not committing any crime if you just be like, Oh, I didn't hear what you said.
No frado.
No, no.
You can just be like, Oh, I didn't hear what they said.
I didn't know that you're asking if that was my first name or not.
You can just be like, Oh, I didn't hear her.
It's just that of you.
And they don't know if you actually heard her or not.
No frado.
A dragon made of magma.
It lives deep inside volcanic caverns.
It is very territorial, creating intruders with giant, invincible bite attack.
Uh...
All right.
You know what, Yabby?
I'll name it after you.
Yabby Goon for your lovely idea of no frado.
Just be like, Oh, I didn't hear them.
I didn't know that they asked me about whether or not I'm an actual doctor or not.
I just didn't correct them because I couldn't hear.
There you go.
How will they know?
They can't fucking...
What are they gonna do?
Put a lie detector on me?
That shit's fake.
That shit's a scam.
A lie detector, all they do is just like, uh, check your heart rate.
So as long as your heart rate is at, like, as long as you can lower your heart rate, you're fine.
It's that easy.
Yes.
It's just lower your heart rate, guys.
Just be legally dead and you should be fine.
Yeah, I'm trying to fish right now.
Just don't get nervous.
Yeah.
He's a pathological liar.
I can do that.
Oh, yeah.
It just has to be a constant rate.
That's fun.
Oh, lava drop.
Okay, let's catch him.
Yeah, it's not a lie.
Exactly.
It's not a lie.
You believe in it.
I believe I can be a doctor.
I just didn't commit to the time yet.
But, like...
I believe that in an alternate universe...
I am a doctor there.
So, technically, I can be a doctor.
Technically, one form of me is a doctor.
So, I am a doctor.
A carefree fire spirit.
It lives in caverns and traveling groups.
It must be careful not to get snuffed up by strong gusts or powerful shockwaves.
You know what?
Dr. Doki.
First name, doctor.
Last name, Doki.
Chat, would you trust Doki was...
Like, Kuba, I think it was a super chat thing.
I could be a doctor too.
I am...
One form of Doki went through seven years of medical school.
You cannot wait to talk to me, Mario?
That means the whole world.
Please, have this.
You deserve it.
Yeah.
Okay, fine.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
He gave me so much shit.
What did you give me?
Where am I?
I'm so lost.
I have not, like, retained...
Information of where I've been.
Alright.
Okay, let's use the rappel.
There must be a...
There must be something here, right?
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
There's a Goomba here.
I, uh...
Lost my stack.
Oh no.
Were you the bottom or the top?
Or the mid?
Okay, there's something...
Oh wait, no.
I've been to this part.
Oh, this lava is really scary.
My trusty shell protects me.
Yours can't do if I find the Koopa Troop anti-lava shell somewhere in the castle.
Oh, I was just there.
He used to swim.
Lord Bowser instructed me to spin in place.
Oh, it's a blue shell.
Koopa.
Oh yeah, that's true.
It might have been the bottom shell.
He got kicked out.
All right, let's get that.
Oh, is it a hand?
Oh, I knew it.
It's always a hand.
Yeah, but the thing about being in the middle is that everybody forgets about you.
Okay, slam 80.
Sucker punch.
Let's just keep the dark move.
I feel like the dark move might be actually good.
No one remembers you, so you can stay in your stack.
Middle stack, child.
Yay!
What is this move?
Oh yeah, no, you don't need HP.
If you...
If you attack first and you hit hard, you'll never need to recover your HP because they never get to hit you.
That's my motto.
Yay!
Bro's bean!
Wait, what's that?
What is that?
Max bean.
Delicious.
That revives.
That...
Gladly...
Wait, what's a bro's bean?
Is it even here?
The fuck is my bro bean?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it raises the maximum.
Oh, okay.
That's useless for me.
Wait, I'm back here.
Where am I?
I'm back here, but where is here exactly?
Oh my god.
Where did I...
Where did I go?
I don't know.
Okay, I came from here.
Okay, and then...
I swim.
Okay, I'll go this way.
And then now I'm here.
Wherever here is.
Oh, okay, there's a toad here.
I never talked to them before.
I keep losing my fate when fish are in this pond.
Isn't that strange?
Alright.
Got the dragon claw.
Okay, I can fight these two.
Hey!
You wanna join a game of tag?
Is this a double battle?
Oh no, I just interrupted your tag.
Alright, sit!
Yay!
They weren't wrong when they said, like, this one would be the longest level.
I'm so confused.
I think it doesn't help that I'm tired.
Like, I'm not retaining any information right now.
I have, like, I have no short-term or I have short-term and long-term memory loss.
It's like that girl from, like, what was it, 50 First Dates, where she forgets every day.
That's one of my favorite movies, by the way.
It's such a good rom-com.
I actually have, like, the special edition DVD for that.
I remember nothing.
Hut, two, three, four.
Uh, no, we're finishing it on...
Was it say Monday?
We're finishing it on Wednesday.
Oh yeah, people were so surprised I posted an early schedule yesterday.
But, like, I literally have, like, everything just planned.
Coincidentally.
Like, I don't have to, like, decide, like, figure out.
Like, I didn't have to wait for anything.
I didn't have to, like, figure out, like...
Um, um, like, per...
Like, if I have to...
Not perms.
God, what am I saying?
I'm an indie with perms.
Um...
I didn't have to, like, be like, oh, can I stream this that day?
It was more so, like...
I didn't have to wait for, like, any permission or anything about, like...
You know, like, sponsors.
And I already had my collab line.
Remember when I said, like, last week?
I was like, oh, yeah, I don't collab line up for this week with Doobie.
But I didn't say it was with Doobie.
I was just like, you know...
Um, but we just didn't decide on the time and date.
And, like, coincidentally, like, um...
You know, she was online on Discord when I asked her, like, oh, you wanna do it this time?
She's like, yeah, let's do it.
So then, you know, everything just went up.
Went, like, you know, fast.
Yeah, D&D collab.
This week.
Because at first, we were just gonna do, like...
At first, it was just, like, learning CS...
Uh, CS...
I almost said CSGO 2.
I didn't realize it was just called CS2.
But at first, we were just gonna do, like, learning CS2.
But then I asked...
Like, she was saying how she actually still enjoyed Overwatch.
And I was like, wow.
You know, I was like, that's impressive.
Like, you know, because, like, there's someone out there that still enjoys Overwatch at its current state.
So then I was like, no, but have you tried Stadium?
Because, you know, Stadium's actually, like, fun, you know?
So, compared to normal Overwatch, jeez, I was very, I was like, oh my god, like, I hope this isn't Stockholm Syndrome, I, no, because, like, Overwatch at its current state is, like, um, oh shit, what, how does that still hate, hate me?
At its current state, obviously, is, like, not the greatest.
But, like, um, Stadium, in my opinion, is actually incredibly fun to play.
I, I absolutely enjoy Stadium.
Like, I play Stadium on my free time sometimes.
Mario, you made it!
Someone said I have a rest stop in this room!
You should take advantage of this and use the chance to rest up!
How?
Oh, you want them heal me?
The power of science is amazing!
Now you can connect to someone else's PC and battle against them!
What?
You're expecting to hear something like this around 21 hours ago?
Sorry, I couldn't find time to make it to Toe Town.
But yeah, and then she said she never tried, um, Stadium before.
So, um, so now I was like, oh my god, we should try it.
And she's like, oh yeah, we can try, do both Stadium and, and CS, you know, after you're done learning CS.
We can cool off with Stadium.
I thought it was a good idea.
Have you seen my bro?
We're making a stack so we can impress a Lady Goomba.
He seems he fell off somewhere along the way.
So that Doki I fought that one time might have been you?
I don't know, maybe.
I always lie and say no.
And the best thing about Overwatch names is that anybody can be Doki Bird in Overwatch.
So like, if, you guys should all name yourself Doki Bird so you can confuse all the other players.
All the other dragoons.
So then when all the other dragoons ask you if you're the real Doki Bird, just say no.
And then they'll think, and then you'll think you're me.
You've been picking up any keys?
You're gonna need at least three and want to get through the entire castle.
But you didn't hear that from me.
What was that revolution?
The Brig revolution that they did?
Oh wait, no.
Oh, okay, sorry.
There are several revolutions in Overwatch.
Yes, Overwatch had like several like in-game revolutions for rank.
One was Brig related, and the other one was Torbjorn.
Like, oh yeah, throw for Defran.
There was throw for Defran, and also the, what was it?
The Brig revolution?
I don't remember the, the Brig one.
I don't remember.
It's like, everybody would name themselves one name to be all like united as a friend against the cause.
But I don't remember what the Brig one was.
Are you thinking of proceeding to the second foot floor?
A word of advice?
Don't be afraid to fall down.
Oh, and can always use escape back to this rest area, if you know what I mean.
I'm used to warm conditions.
But this place is ridiculous!
How does anyone get anything done like this?
I don't remember what it was called.
You guys remember?
But yeah, anyway, on a topic of that...
Um...
Just re- You guys should like, rename yourself Stokeybird.
And then like, and then people would be like, Where the fuck are all these Dokeybirds coming from?
I don't remember.
I remember it was like, something related to Brig.
But I don't remember.
Was it like, Ban Brig or something?
I don't fucking remember.
It was so long ago.
The great Dokeybird.
And then they ask you if you're the real Dokeybird.
Just say no.
So then like, no one will know.
Which one's the real Dokeybird.
They'll be like, can the real Dokeybird please stand up?
And then I'll be there too.
And then there'll be like, two Dokeybirds in the same...
In the same game.
People will be like, which one's the real Dokeybird?
And now we'll both say no.
But they'll never know that I was the real Dokeybird.
I am...
Oh yeah, it was Delete Brig!
Yeah, alright, so there was a Delete Brig revolution.
Where like, everyone was naming themselves Delete Brig, even the high ELOs.
And they'll be like, they'll be like, what is your cause?
And I'll be like, I don't know, I just thought it would be funny.
They'll be like, what is... what are they trying to revolutionize?
And I was like, I don't know, it's just funny.
For the laughs.
They'll just be like, they'll just be like, it just suddenly spawns out of nowhere.
Okay, now I'm room two.
There was a Mercy revolution too, I don't, there's so many.
Like, Overwatch has existed for so long, that it felt like it went through its own like, history textbook.
Like, it has, I swear, it has its own history textbook.
It went through so much lore.
This thing is, the thing is...
Overwatch created like, a sub-community of like, for like, Mercy players.
Like, it's like their own little community and like, lifestyle.
Being a Mercy player.
It's actually, it's actually so interesting.
Lali, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Francisco, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Lali, thank you again for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I always thought the... wait... Last Resort?
Oh, I wasn't... What was this?
What's Last Resort?
That sounds like a cool move.
Oh, okay, never mind.
That seems like a terrible move.
Uh, I always thought the ending was fucked because they had kids.
Imagine waking up eight months pregnant and you're told you already had another kid.
Wait, what... What was... What is the context for that?
What?
I wasn't paying attention!
What... What context was that?
Oh, 50 first dates.
Oh, okay.
I was like... Wait, that was the ending?
Oh... Oh my god!
I forgot that was the ending.
Okay, never mind.
That's a little fucked.
I just thought it was so cute, you know, in the beginning of the...
I did not really... I... Oh yeah, it's King Boo!
I... I did not remember that ending.
Oh no, for some reason I just thought she was cured.
At the end.
I... I was like, love cures everything.
Even a brain...
Even when you're missing half your brain.
Love can cure anything.
Oh no, the love just grew back part of her brain.
Love always wins.
With the power of love, anything is possible.
Nah, I'm not gonna fight you.
Not as long as Lord Bowser keeps stationing us directly in front of Bullet Bill Blasters.
Oh my god, I'm so... Oh my god, it's the fucking Super Mario Bros.
3 game.
I love Super Mario Bros.
3!
How did you get here?
How...
Okay, to be fair, I haven't watched 50 First Dates in a long time.
Guys...
Can you win against this?
How did they get here?
Exactly!
It's like, no matter where you go, you can escape the Super Mario Bros.
3 game.
No, my money!
Oh, this is where I should get...
Oh, I would have to get new captures here.
I just forgot about that.
I just realized I would get new captures here.
Okay, so I should have like...
Escape.
Where is the escape key?
Okay, escape rope.
Okay.
Because I want to heal real quick.
And then...
I want to heal real quick.
So that won't die.
And then...
Turn off...
Okay, I should register this.
List.
And then...
Get rid of this.
Actually, I should register this too.
So I can...
Conveniently use it later.
I can...
Uh...
It was here.
Bum-ba-dum, bum-ba-dum, bum-ba-dum, bum.
Yay!
New captures!
New goons!
New prisoners!
Okay.
Don't worry.
I have a lot of them.
Yay!
Not yay!
Come on!
Oh yeah!
I read like recent Pokemon lore.
Of like...
How like Pokeballs work.
So like...
Basically like...
When you're in the Pokeball...
It's basically like...
A little mini environment.
In the...
Pokeball...
Don't resist.
Like...
Stop resisting.
Um...
In like...
In the little world.
And it's like...
They get to decide...
If they want to stay in that world.
In that little ball.
Like...
Come on!
It's a nice...
It's a nice world.
It's a nice little world.
In my little ball.
Get in here!
Don't worry.
I can Stockholm Syndrome them enough.
Come on!
There's fun in here.
All your friends are having fun.
Live in the ball!
You don't have to work...
Don't worry about your family.
They'll be...
They'll be okay.
She can remarry.
Don't worry.
See?
Look!
He...
He accepted his fate.
An avid sports fan that knows which football is best.
It uses its head more than many may think.
But a concussion leaves its mind to be more than desirable.
Holy fuck.
Alright.
There's no taxes in the ball!
Get in here!
Alright.
Who wants to have...
Brain problems?
Who wants to be my special...
Special little guy?
Johnny might die.
He...
I'll take it!
Alright.
Let's see.
He...
I hate taxes with me.
Alright, I'll give it to... Alright.
Roll... Goon.
Don't worry about the concussions.
I think there's a doctor in the ball.
Yeah... I don't remember where I've gone.
And then... Oh wait, no, I came from here.
Yeah, I remember now.
I came from here, yeah.
Have I talked to him yet?
Evil around me is a poser.
I have... I haven't sent...
But Lord Poser and Morden that isn't... What?
What accent was that?
I'm so fucking confused.
What did he say?
What language was that?
Huh?
Yeah, I'm like, excuse me?
I gave up reading that.
I could barely read in the first place.
Have I been here?
No, okay, I haven't.
I love the smell of lava in nondescript time of day.
Yeah, I think that Koopa is also his...
That's also Lord Bowser's special little guy.
Oh, I forgot.
He's paralyzed.
He jumped off another bed.
Yeah!
T-Rex.
That's the T-Rex, right?
Oh no, it's just a regular guy.
Alright, time to sit.
Forgot the T-Rex is literally called T-Rex.
Yeah!
Don't worry, he likes it.
Oh, well, he's dead.
He liked it too much.
He spoke the language of Hootenha.
Meep, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is that said...
Okay, rock record.
Okay, I...
I was like, wait, what does that say?
Immobile, next turn.
Okay.
Oh,
fuck it.
I was like, excuse me?
How...
What kind...
Did they just add that move in?
I thought that said homewrecker.
I'm like...
I was like, oh my god!
Heftly's a homewrecker?
I was like, what kind of move?
What do you do with that move?
How do you use it?
Okay, maybe here?
Oh my god, this is Super Mario Bros 3 Bros again.
I saw them again.
What did you do, Heftly?
What did you do to charge his wife?
No, I'm back here.
Where am I?
Back here!
Okay, I haven't gone this way.
Yeah, this is new.
Mario.
Okay, thank god.
This place is new.
Oh no.
You'll be fine.
Okay, guys.
I knew you'd be fine.
Power of gambling.
Don't worry, Mario.
I'll block the bullet...
...bullet nails for you.
It won't hurt much.
Okay.
That's not blocking, Toad.
You like, walked away from it.
That'll be fine.
Guys, it's not like I have another 10k lying around, guys.
He'll be fine, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait, I need to fight him.
Get blasted, nerd!
Plumber!
Okay.
He can survive this.
Yay!
Gambling!
See, I told you guys.
I knew it.
I knew he could survive this.
But what's on the left side?
What's on this side?
Oh, I need the key.
Okay.
So maybe the left side will get me the key then.
Okay, no.
Where the fuck am I?
Okay, I know where that...
Okay, so I know...
I know that's where the actual door is.
Now I just need to find the key.
Okay, now I'm back here.
God fucking...
Okay.
Where the fuck is the key?
Drop through the lava squares?
Oh, yeah!
They're like, you can drop through!
But where?
Where...
Oh my god.
This is why his wife left him.
His wife was like, please, Bowser.
Please.
We gotta spend the money on...
Oh, it's your whole wallet.
We gotta spend the money...
On the...
On our fucking A plus kids college fund.
It's like...
And then he's like, no, our castle needs to be bigger.
Wait.
I'm back in the...
Oh my god.
I'm back in the basement.
Are you...
Actually, I don't even think his wife left him.
I think he lost his wife in this house somewhere.
I think maybe he just lost his wife in this house.
Like, maybe I'll just find Bowser's wife somewhere here.
Oh my god.
His wife is still here.
Maybe the castle is his wife?
Oh, like some monster house shit?
Alright, I'll follow it.
Where is this area?
Where the fuck is this area?
Oh my god.
I'm so tired.
Okay, does it take me back to the rest area?
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'm putting the E-gag thing on.
Alright.
This is the...
This is the worst area for the most directionally...
Directionally challenged bird.
Oh my god, where did I come from?
I don't remember.
They all look the same.
Oh, these doors look the same.
I don't remember.
They all look the fucking same.
Did I?
Okay.
I don't think I've been here.
Okay, this is new.
Oh, thank god.
Mario, you're here.
Then that means...
Ha!
You beat Power Plunk.
I hope he wasn't too easy.
Because I'm not holding back.
It's like a fucking face or something.
Okay, I figured it out.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
What the fuck?
That took half my HP!
Did he, like, explode?
Like, is it intestines?
They're, like, on dad's, like, fucking skin?
And it, like...
And, like, he just has trauma?
From what he did?
What the fuck does Inner Town even mean?
I just popped a balloon?
Oh, no.
It's okay.
He moves...
He's fast enough.
I told you, guys.
If I level him enough...
He'll eventually be fast enough.
Oh, my god.
He ends it with Goomastack?
That's so sad.
It's like, you know, you know, his, like, relatives and, like, cousins and nephews and nieces need a job.
And then he's like, I guess you can, like, be in my party, you know?
Alright, we got the bubble key.
Alright, nice.
Wait, but why?
Why?
Why put me back here?
Just a scape rope back.
Alright, here.
Heal dad now.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
No.
Not here.
Okay, now I have the key.
I think I got all the captures, right?
Pretty sure.
Alright.
Nice.
Now we're in the third room.
Wait.
We're not in the third room?
Where are we?
Alright, I just want to be sure if there's anything new here.
Alright, fall off the roof.
And then...
Oh, okay.
I'll just use that again then.
Alright, nice.
You beat Power Blanc and Goomp?
Look, I'm one day away from vacation.
And one step away from lava.
So let's not drag this out.
Alright.
Final...
Final Goon.
Get that Final Goon out of here.
No, my money!
I'm gonna pay my mortgage now!
I wonder...
Okay.
If you, like, put...
If you put them in the ball...
You don't have to feed them, right?
I assume, like, if we're Pokemon lore...
Like, they never have to be fed again if they're in the Pokeball and you put them in a box.
You do?
What about all the boxed Pokemons?
Yeah, they can't get hungry if they're in the PC.
Right?
They're just data.
They die?!
Who the fuck is feeding Ash's Poke...
Oh,
they're at a ranch?!
I have to pay rent for...
I have to pay...
Ranch feed?!
Yeah, but who's paying Professor Oak?!
Ash is not paying shit.
He's still 10.
All right.
That should be...
Wait, where's Bowser's area?
Oh!
Oh, it's at the main gate.
Okay.
I was, like, a little confused.
I have the spirit.
I'm just a little confused.
Yeah, but what...
What does his mom do?
What job does his mom have?
I mean, I guess if you start losing money, you can just eat one of your Pokemon.
Mario!
Quit your yelling.
Your brother isn't gonna save you this time.
I mean, that's what Magikarp is.
They're just fish.
Yeah, quit your yelling.
You're gonna stay blocked up till Papa and Pizza gets here.
You actually want a pizza, bro?
Wait, you still kidnapped me.
I didn't even get a chance to command my catchers.
This isn't fair!
Fair?
Who said anything about fair?
Ha ha ha.
He he he.
Papa!
I trapped him and took his Power Stars and caps, just like you asked.
Bowser, this was your plan?
Of course I planned this.
That's my kind of thing.
I helped you get the Power Stars so I could take them for myself in the end.
I thought what we had was special, bro.
Where are none of our memories together real?
Ha ha ha.
You can't be serious.
Get a load of this guy.
And then Luigi has trust issues for the rest of his life.
Yippee.
Yeah, what a chump.
Lord Bowser really played you.
No.
I'm always the bad guy.
You shouldn't trust me.
Is that really what you want?
I got what I wanted.
Mario!
You're here!
Bowser trapped me and took all my stuff.
Also, do you have your emergency pizza stash?
Papa didn't trap you!
I did!
Grrrr!
Papa!
I wanna fight Mario!
Let me show you how strong I am!
Junior, you have a very important job.
I'll make sure Luigi doesn't escape.
And keeping Comic entertained.
Yes, and I haven't been here the whole time, your rashness.
Mario is my rival!
And I'll not let this mushroom-munching, CAPTURE CRUSHING!
BRICK BREAKING!
SOULMATE STEALING!
PARKING BIN HERO!
RUIN MY PLANS AGAIN!
Comic, have you assembled...
THE TEAM?
YES, MY CAP CHAMPION!
OH MY GOD!
Comic has crafted the strongest party ever!
This battle will mark your reign, Mario!
And I will finally have my wish!
I mean, you can have Peach if you want.
I mean, there's so many options.
I mean...
My ex-girlfriend, Pauline...
I think she wants me back.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
I'll say it.
I think...
I think I'd pick Pauline over...
Princess Peach.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Better!
Thank you for the reign!
Thank you!
I hope you had a great stream!
Better!
I'm fighting Bowser right now.
In my Super Mario mind.
I'm also...
I also...
My hot take today was that...
I think Pauline is a better girlfriend than Princess Peach.
Because at least she doesn't get kidnapped all the time!
Bro, and she's...
Okay, to be fair, Princess Peach is like Queen of Toad Town.
But like Queen of the Toads.
But then she's also Queen of the Toads.
Like...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
That's the thing.
She is Queen.
But she's also Queen of the Toads.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Yeah, but she got kidnapped one time!
And then she learned her lesson!
She learned not to have that happen again!
Alright.
That's right.
Time to sit on him.
Also, like...
Pauline has like...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I guess I don't sit on him!
Oh, fuck!
Oh!
Whoa!
You know what?
I trust Hefli.
So far...
Okay.
True.
But like...
Okay.
Time to use the homewrecker.
You got this, Hefli.
Don't worry.
You know where his wife is, right?
Alright.
Haha.
Hahaha!
Kamik said he made the strongest party.
Just because he's in it.
He nodded!
Hahaha!
He knows!
Alright.
Okay, the only biggest issue right now...
Is that Dad is out of commission!
And like, he's still gonna... Okay, I trust you.
I trust you, my son, that I keep in the attic.
My attic son.
Where no one knows.
Oh my god, Mecha Chop?
What the fuck?
Where did that guy come from?
Mother.
Oh my god, that's fine.
Now I... Okay, now I fight Bowser.
Okay.
Alright, I believe in you.
Oh.
Wait, you're dragon?
But you get hurt by dragon moves?
Why are you your own weakness?
Oh my god.
Guys, I...
I didn't know.
Alright.
Your sacrifice will not be in vain.
Okay, where is it?
Where is it?
Don't worry.
Your sacrifice will not be in vain.
It better not be.
Die for the cause, my attic son.
Goodbye.
Die.
Yay.
Dad's back.
Alright, Storm's real.
Look, Dad needs more XP, guys.
Look, he's so hungry.
He's...
He's starving, guys.
He needs more XP.
Look at him.
He could have been level 70 right now.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
Okay.
He's so hungry, guys.
Oh, this is bad.
That's fine.
He's so hungry.
He needs more.
No, no, no.
We have max mushroom.
There you go.
It was worth it.
It was so worth it, guys.
Okay, as long as, like...
As long as that doesn't do a critical hit, we're so fine.
Nice.
See?
Look at that.
He's so hungry, guys.
He needs more food.
Okay, Sumo, bro.
I should be faster than him.
Statistically, I should be.
Like, we're...
They're both, like, big bone.
Oh, okay.
Never.
Goodbye.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, wait.
He should be...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wait.
No.
Never.
Goodbye, Heffley.
I might have fucked up there.
No, you're faster.
You should be faster.
It's okay.
It's fine.
He just has one more.
Okay, Mecha Chomp.
You know what?
I believe.
Brown is stronger than metal, right?
What's...
How high, horse?
I don't know what this does.
Oh.
Whoops.
I knew you won't disappoint me.
My son that gets to be out in public.
Right?
Damn it.
You better not be laughing because I'm not.
No.
Give Papa some space.
It's clear that I can't beat you.
Not even what the strongest team come I can make.
Why is that?
Am I really that weak?
Am I not a great commander and leader?
Bro, you just don't have the power of friendship and love.
Bowser, you're stronger than you think.
I think I speak for all of us when I sing.
We are terrified of your power, bro.
Bro, you may not be great at this game.
That doesn't mean you're weak.
I supported you through your journey since the Jungle Kingdom.
And I hope I helped you become stronger.
Wow, what a real bro.
Luigi.
Hmm.
I mean...
Green Stash!
This is like...
A doomed yaoi!
Ha ha ha ha!
This is like...
Unrequented love.
Bowser's chasing after Peach.
But he has...
He already has his soulmate right there.
Waiting for him.
Ha ha ha ha!
That might be the smartest thing you have ever said.
How could I be so stupid?
Hm.
I was so blinded by competition.
That I didn't realize I grabbed my own wits.
Thank you for reminding me that I have eight power stars and you don't!
Who cares about a wish from Peaches?
My wish right now is to destroy you!
Right here!
Right now!
What the fuck?
He can just...
Do that?
Luigi!
What the fuck?
You had eight power stars all on!
You didn't go big!
I'm going to turn you into a fine red mist!
Not unless you turn me into a fine green mist!
I'll not let you fight Bowser by yourself!
This is my fight too!
Ha ha ha ha!
I will end the Mario Brothers!
Let's go, bro!
Wait, guys!
Guys!
Wait, wait a minute!
Oh, wait!
Oh, he's fully healed!
Thank God!
And you bring out your Goomba stack!
As the first one!
Ha ha ha!
Bro!
Why didn't you bring out your starter?
Ha ha ha!
Why didn't you bring out that Goomba stack?
What are you gonna do?
Walk very, very...
Ha ha ha!
This is it.
All right.
Impressive.
Wait, can I catch him?
Ha ha ha!
Is he...
He technically is wild, right?
Ha ha ha!
Oh, I can't.
Unlucky.
Why is he hitting me and not the Goomba...
Oh, of course he fucking gets the last...
The killing move.
Of course he does.
Of course the Goomba stack gets the kill...
After everything I did.
After I was the one that got the crit move.
Ha ha ha!
I just didn't gain 2 XP for that?
No!
This...
This isn't...
Happening!
The Goomba stack MVP.
Of course he fucking kill steals me.
You know what this is happening?
Me kicking your butt!
This is for stealing my power stars!
This is for bullying my brother!
And this is for breaking my heart!
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay, at least...
Ha ha ha!
Okay, I need to pee.
I can't be a sec.
Okay, that...
Ha ha ha!
No!
Luigi!
Oh, Luigi!
Oh, my God!
He is going through his...
Heartbreak right now!
Alan, forward, fight size!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh, no!
We loved you!
Ha ha ha!
Why?
You are breaking his heart!
Ha ha ha!
I'm sorry!
He did everything for you!
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha!
Hey!
Luigi, my friend!
FRIEND!
Ha ha ha!
Let's say we forget about all this and go back to playing in the Cap challenge!
Oh my God!
And he said friend!
Poor Luigi!
How are you gonna recover from a broken heart?
And he gets friendzoned too.
Oh, bro.
Together.
Come on, just me and you.
I think I'm ready to break up our partnership.
It's not you.
No, it is you.
It's not me.
I'll give it you on my heart.
What?
Luigi deserves better.
He thought he could fix him, guys.
Luigi thought he could fix him.
But he's not fixable.
You are with me, bro.
Don't worry, bro.
I'll get you a rebound.
It's not the same.
All Luigi wants was a 10 feet tall turtle monster.
This isn't the end.
It's not the same, guys.
Daisy just doesn't...
Unless she turns into the elephant.
We did it, bro.
I got my power stars back.
As well as the ones assigned to the Molten Kingdom.
Here, this one is yours.
Casting you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Bowser Jr. had to witness another divorce, guys.
Poor Bowser Jr. He's only a little guy and he went through two divorces.
I'm happy I spent time with Bowser.
He'll never forget the memories, guys.
Even though he said he wanted me for my power stars.
I don't think that's all that true.
I really believed we were having fun together with the cap challenge.
And that we were becoming friends.
Maybe more friends.
He said in his heart.
But, I'm sorry.
That was ignorant to everything.
And that caused you so much trouble.
I was looking through everything with gross tinted glasses.
But, didn't realize that he was already a flag, bro.
I really believed I became stronger as a person through this game.
And I'm all ready to prove that for you.
What's that sound?
The power stars.
There.
A voice rings out of, from nowhere.
Bearer of all eight power stars.
Return to Toetown at once.
And board the ship in the west of town.
From there, go to the Mushroom King Hill.
Where your final challenge awaits.
Our final challenge!
We have to head to Toetown quick!
Now, don't keep me waiting, bro.
Let's see who can get the wish first.
Alright, we did it.
We beat up Luigi's ex-boyfriend.
I told him.
I told him he wasn't good for him.
But Luigi was like, no, bro.
I can fix him.
Please.
You just don't know him behind...
Behind closed doors.
Betty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He is nice to me.
Bro, you don't understand.
I was like...
Is this what you want to do to your mama?
You're breaking on your mama's power heart.
What?
I shouldn't even think what you were like on Tumblr.
Stop inserting, dude.
Wait!
He was the one that said...
You broke my heart!
What the fuck was I supposed to infer with that?
Luigi literally was like...
You broke my heart, palsy!
What was I supposed to...
What was I supposed to say with that?
Okay, let's see.
Get the warp...
Wait, what?
How can I leave?
Warp back here.
You're supposed to infer friendship.
Just friends.
Make way for Princess of the Mushroom Kingdom!
Princess Toadstool!
They're just really good friends.
Some say roommates.
Mario...
You've done wonderfully.
Thank you so much for defeating Bowser.
How do you know about your deeds in the Molten Kingdom?
Ho ho!
Did you not hear?
The call of the Power Stars.
Once you collected all in.
All involved in the cap challenge.
Heard the call, Master Mario.
As such!
We're off to Mushroom here in...
Who's taste?
That's right!
Do you want to come...
Oh wait.
That's right.
Do you want to come with us, Mario?
We have a boat prepared already.
Then...
Just follow us.
Alright.
That's cool.
Oh, there's the boat!
A princess!
Toadsworth!
What brings you to my humble docks?
Bring us to Mushroom Hill, young seller!
Who's taste?
Of course!
Toadsworth!
Go right on the hill!
I don't know.
Thanks for accompanying us, Mario.
Really, you must be going.
As we have a business to attend to at Mushroom Hill.
Here, though.
Take this as thanks.
Oh yeah, I got Max Bean.
We'll never catch a boo, guys.
I hope that will help you on your challenge.
Wait, did I catch a boo?
No, we did, right?
I don't remember.
We caught so many.
Oh, Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If one got bit by a snake, do you think the other one?
Good luck, Mario.
You'll need it.
Mario.
Alright, that's...
I should've used that voice.
All these stories are top-notch!
I knew I could count on Mushroom Hill.
We're nothing but the greatest.
Hey, Mario!
Remember me?
I'm the first toad from 1-2!
I managed to get all eight...
Wait, there's no way.
There's no way.
How?
What?
How were you able to get all eight Power Stars?
I did not see you in the Multi Kingdom.
How were you able to beat Bowser Jr.?
Oh man.
I can't wait to see the final battles of the Cap Challenge.
Professor E-Gag has set up a way for us to watch the event live.
It's gonna be awesome.
I wonder who's gonna be a victor of the Cap Challenge.
You?
Your brother?
Maybe someone else entirely?
Bro, the acid paid to win.
There's no way.
I refuse to believe.
This off a Silver Glem?
What the fuck does a Battle Cap do?
Okay, that's a TM shop.
Oh, take my picture!
Oh.
Come give us a comment before your big battle!
Oh, I already talked to him.
So much to do in order to prepare, am I right?
Wonder what these battle caps I get for you.
I'm sorry!
You're not paying with level caps enabled!
Don't you like?
Oh.
No.
I'll make sure, like, I don't accidentally turn that on.
Okay, I have to...
Like, that's so scary.
I can't spam because I could accidentally turn it on.
I have to be careful with that.
Help me!
I serve you!
Okay.
That guy's a cookie guy.
Oh!
My fortune told!
Okay.
Hello.
Tell my fortune.
If you offer me a battle cap, I can raise the potential of your capture.
Oh, I don't have any.
Alright.
Yeah, I know I can spam B, but I'm so paranoid.
I'm way too paranoid.
Wait, is that Metal Sonic?
Who's that?
I wonder if he's here.
Luigi.
Please don't hold...
Oh wait, is that Kamek?
Please don't hold it against us.
Win this.
Challenge for us.
He looked like Metal Sonic from this perspective.
It's just a Koopa admin.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
Oh, yeah, I should buy...
Oh, I should buy a cap.
You're right.
Okay.
It's right here.
And then we'll...
We'll raise the potential.
I have enough.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
There's a question mark here.
Oh, I did...
Okay.
I didn't even...
I didn't even have to do that.
Alright.
Make him stronger.
I decide...
Okay, speed.
I...
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Is...
Is he crush attack or special attack, guys?
We doesn't need speed.
As long as...
As long as he can one-shot.
Is like...
Please come back.
Let's keep doing it.
Make him stronger.
He doesn't need speed.
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, he's already as strong as possible?
Wait, I can only do it once?
That's fine.
109... Oh, he's a big boy.
Alright, there you go.
You just need one... Oh, try speed?
Can I do one on speed?
Alright.
Okay, now he's just a little bit faster now.
Alright, let's see.
Nice.
There we go.
You only cap him once, it just raises IVs to 31, the max.
Oh, okay.
So, it's okay if I do it twice to speed and attack, right?
Alright.
Oh my god, he's actually a little bit faster.
Okay, that's good.
Nice.
Alright, now he's my big boy.
That's right.
Excuse me, please come over here for a moment.
Only those with all eight passers.
Let me check how many you've attained.
Yay!
Oh, this is like Victory Road.
But it's Rainbow Road!
Oh, that's so clever!
Wait, it changes his nature?
What's his nature now?
Sassy.
Oh, he's so sassy.
I don't know anything about nature.
I don't know how the nature stuff works.
Okay.
Wait, okay.
Before we do...
I heard there...
Do we...
Can we access the secret now or no?
I actually don't know where the secret is though.
Is it back at home?
Mario's pad?
I know about the secret.
But like, I don't know how to get the secret.
I don't know how to do it.
It's like here.
I have to beat the game!
I don't think you're ready.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
I have to beat the game for the secret.
Rainbow Road is ruthless!
I have faith in your cutting skills!
I know as you're going off the edge!
Oh my god.
Wait, I want to fight him.
I need more...
...stuff for a dad.
Oh my god, it's...
It's your brother.
Okay, I don't think I can...
I don't know.
He seems pretty fucking big.
And then...
He is...
He definitely looks like a cuckoo bird.
Like, my actual son got like, thrown off its nest.
And you guys just took...
Nice, goodbye.
I was...
I was just trying to merge!
Oh my god.
What?
Wait, how do you do this?
Excuse me?
Oh, I can't do it slow.
Oh my god.
That...
That's hell.
That's...
That's actual hell.
Hey, did these boost battles look like a little third party deal?
I know I'm supposed to drive on and I'm all fearless and stuff.
I can't help but be scared.
Oh my god.
That reminds me.
I heard about, um...
You know that new Mario?
Uh...
The new Mario Kart game?
And then there's apparently a new game mode called like, mirror mode or something.
I saw a tweet being like, to unlock this mode, you need a master's degree or some shit.
Because no one, no one knows how to actually unlock mirror mode.
Like, some guy was like, you need to do this.
And you need to get 10 Peach Coins, then you need to win every cup game, every trophy in first place.
And then like, there's like 20 different answers on how to unlock this mode.
And the guy was like, this proves my point.
Yeah, there's apparently some secret...
There's some secret hidden mode called mirror mode in the new Mario Kart game.
And no one knows how to unlock it, actually.
Just pay Nintendo.
Oh, is it always a thing?
Oh, I didn't know that.
Someone was just like, how do you...
How the fuck do you actually unlock...
Like, apparently it's like, no one knows the real way to unlock it, though, for the current game.
Oh my god, I hate this.
How do I...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, this is hell.
This is actually hell.
This...
Oh my god.
But
like...
I give up.
I...
I can't.
I cannot do the shortcut.
Oh, fuck that.
I can't.
I give up.
Underclock your CP.
Don't give up.
But it's so easy, though.
Oh my god.
I love...
Oh, I saw like a screenshot of like, when the game first came out in the multiplayer mode.
And then literally everybody was just a cow.
I mean, good choice, though.
I'd be the cow, too, if I paid $80.
And also another...
Another, what, $200 plus for the Nintendo Switch, too.
Cow meta.
Oh, $450?
That's like, $600 Canadian!
Holy fuck!
That's more expensive than a PS5!
You know what?
Okay, I think the craziest shit about Switch games, or like, Nintendo games, is that they're never on discount.
I think that is the craziest part.
Wait, can I encounter this?
There are mods on this?
I have it off?
Oh no, I have it on.
Or off.
Alright, fight me.
Don't be afraid to switch to the water portions!
I'll be right back to your car!
Once you're done!
Wait, what?
How do I get on the water portions?
Oh!
There we go.
No, I never...
I never get consoles on launch.
I never do that.
I wait until...
I wait until, like, they fix some stuff before I do.
Because every console on launch, there's always a problem.
It's never worth it.
Hey!
Careful where you're driving that thing!
Oh shit.
Alright, time to throw him.
Oh shit, never mind.
Goodbye, Dad.
Of course they have Drift!
You think they're gonna fix it?
You're just gonna buy a new Joy-Con any...
Hahahaha!
You...
You're just gonna buy a new Joy-Con anyway!
It's been like, 10 plus years!
If no one has done anything, you think they'll still do something?
Hahahaha!
Acupuncture.
Or acupressure.
I'll just fucking...
Just punch the fish.
Oh my god.
I literally used the wrong character for this.
And this new set of controllers don't have a class action lawsuit.
So, they won't fix them for free either.
I think that's the crazy part.
I read, like, what they said...
What was it?
Um...
That they, like...
They're willing to replace Joy-Cons that have drift.
But, like...
This...
They didn't learn from it.
And, like, the Switch 2 Joy-Cons have the same issue as the...
The first Joy-Con.
I think that's the wildest part.
Oh, why did I send out ground?
Alright.
That's fine.
I was like, wait a minute.
Why did I send out ground?
Oh.
It's okay.
He didn't use water.
That's awkward.
What?
How did you miss?
Oh no.
Alright.
If he has to die...
Then you must join your brother.
You're so linked.
What?
It's okay.
It doesn't hurt that much.
We can show him how it's done.
You know what?
Dot, dot, dot.
Dragoon?
Maybe you're not so bad.
Mother, look!
Look, mother!
I did it!
Are you proud of me, mother?
Ray, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Mother!
Love us!
Oh, fuck.
How much more can it go up?
Oh.
That's awkward.
Oh, it doesn't even affect them.
Oh.
It'll be fine, right?
Whoa.
That's awkward.
Oh, and humor.
Oh, another...
Oh, another sword stance.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
We have half three.
That...
That was awkward, guys.
Oh, man.
Okay.
I really...
Oh, and another stamina.
Okay.
Oh.
It'll be fine, right?
It'll be fine.
Everything will be fine.
Oh.
Another stamina.
Oh, shit.
Guys, it's fine.
I have a secret weapon.
Stop making him stronger.
Um.
How are you poisoned?
You're floating!
Okay.
There you go.
This is my secret weapon.
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, shit.
Uh.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
No.
No, guys.
I have an idea.
Okay.
He's poisoned.
Guys.
I have...
I have an idea.
All your friends are dead, Dad.
But it's okay.
You're still alive.
You'll stop.
We're not using explosions!
We can't get him!
This is like our last chance!
Okay, we have Storm Throat.
Oh, my God.
We did it!
All your friends are dead, but you're alive.
Here to take up all the XP.
Here.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
All right.
Okay, let's make sure he doesn't die of poison.
Real quick.
All your friends are dead, but it's okay.
As long as you're alive, it's okay.
Oh, it's the luma!
Holy shit, that clubba was jacked up.
Okay.
I wonder if there's any captures here that I don't have, though.
Oh, is that another ref?
That's gonna beat me up?
No, it's fine.
That's gonna take me to the end, right?
Us Lacticus are on the safety team for Rainbow Road.
They pick you up if you happen to fall off the track.
The few of us are bored, and they want a piece of the action for themselves.
I believe in him.
He's got this.
Oh, is this new?
Oh, yeah, it is new.
Look out!
Oh my god, he has five... Okay.
Okay, this is victory.
Dad's got this, I believe!
He can solo them all!
Oh, it's like all the Yoshis!
Dad sweep!
Let's go!
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, he can live through this.
Guys, I might have...
Oh, god.
Okay, guys.
Maybe I should have...
Maybe...
Guys, maybe I should have...
Upped my defense as well.
Uh...
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's fine.
Dragon doesn't do much, right?
Oh, okay.
All right, maybe like...
You know...
Aww...
Maybe I should have...
Ooh, uh...
Maybe, uh...
Maybe I should have actually, uh...
Invested in, uh...
Oh, my god.
And you're paralyzed!
It's okay, he still got it.
He's still a survivor!
Okay, that's a normal Yoshi.
He just can't do shit.
Oh, thank god.
Normal Yoshi can't do shit.
I don't know if I should risk it.
I don't...
He's paralyzed.
Okay, okay.
All right.
Normally...
Normally, I'd be like, let's go gambling!
But like, I...
I don't know.
Might be not the right time.
It might not be the right time to go gambling anymore.
I feel like he might actually kill him.
Oh, yeah.
No, that...
Yeah, that...
Yeah, he would...
Yeah, he would have been fucking dead.
Yeah, yeah.
No, he...
Yeah.
Yeah, he would definitely not survive that.
Oh, thank god.
Yay!
You live!
The waterfall blinded me!
All right, we're good to go.
Okay.
Hey, Mario!
I finally caught up with you, bro.
I've been meaning to ask this since...
Ever since we defeated Bowser together.
But, do you think we can have one final battle?
I want to give you all I got with the friends I made along the way.
Wait.
Can you heal me?
Luigi, can you...
Wait.
Luigi.
Luigi, wait!
Wait!
I don't...
Usually, you'd heal him!
Luigi, why didn't you heal me?
You got...
Mario, that's a cool team?
What do you mean?
All I have is dad right now.
What do you mean team?
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Okay, it's not...
It's nothing personal, kid.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
I still have a lot of golden shroomies learned.
He's gonna be a player one soon.
Hit him while he's weak.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
What the fuck, Luigi?
Okay, this is all I have.
He knows what he's doing.
Oh, thank God.
When his bro needed the most, Luigi with the steel chair.
Oh, my God.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Luigi learned from the best karaoke ambushing you out of the Zubac Cave exit level stats.
Or strats.
Okay.
That's still alive.
Somehow.
He's still...
Topedo, use explosion.
I would if I could, guys.
If he didn't fucking...
Maybe have only one mod right now.
Can't believe that is a really competitive scene for this game.
Who am I thinking for the super chat?
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Thank God I didn't.
I told my God.
Imagine if I, like, if he just dies from that.
Imagine if he just dies from the fucking recoil.
Okay, I still have five more.
I can heal now.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
This is so awkward.
You can take this.
I...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
I just have explosions.
Oh, no.
Okay.
This is fine.
I have a thing that gives me pee pee.
Where's the pee pee?
Pee pee pee, where are you?
We need...
We need it.
Okay, where's the syrup?
Okay, here you go.
All right.
As long as he doesn't do...
Doesn't...
Oh, he does earthquake again.
Wait, he does earthquake again.
As long as it's not a critical hit, we should be fine.
Jesus Christ.
I am like...
We're not losing to Luigi, guys.
He might have caught me when I'm at my weakest.
It's okay.
He shall have...
Oh, my God.
How much...
How much earthquake are you gonna use?
Okay, we're still okay.
We're still okay.
Throw that fucker.
Throw him.
That's right.
Throw him off a cliff.
At least...
Okay.
I'm risking it.
I move first.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Okay.
Fuck.
Maybe I was distracted by this rainbow.
Okay.
I don't trust...
I'm sorry, Dad.
I...
I don't trust you.
We have another golden shroom.
Eat.
Eat, Dad.
The heavier you are, the more damage you do.
Oh, my God.
Of course, he uses brain burn.
I don't know if he should eat.
I don't know.
I think he's faster.
I...
No, I don't trust it.
I think he's faster.
I...
I legitly think he's faster.
Okay.
Eat.
Keep eating, Dad.
Oh, my God.
Last one.
Keep eating.
We can outlive this.
We can outlive it.
Yes.
We did it.
Eat the mushroom.
Oh, that was so close.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, we did it.
Oh, my God.
We actually lived from a movie.
That was close.
Wow, Robro.
Bro, you really mastered this game, haven't you?
Yes, with the power of eating right now.
Don't worry, though.
I'll catch up in no time.
Just you see.
By the way, are you prepared for the rest of the room?
Here, let me heal you up before I leave.
You fucking whore.
Well, I'mma go on ahead.
Good luck, bro.
Thanks, bro.
Thanks.
Thanks for the heal, bro.
I really appreciate it.
If you made it this far, you're probably sitting on tunnels of coin you could have used to stock up on supplies.
Thank you, Luigi.
Why didn't you do that before?
Look at Tokyo's plot, wherever.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, he lived.
He actually lived.
Oh my god, when I saw his HP go down and down and down, I was like, No way.
Wait, that wasn't half HP.
Oh my god, now he, thank fucking god.
It wasn't stopping.
I got really, really worried when it didn't stop.
Alright, nice.
Oh, no.
No, we're fine.
Oh my god.
Oh no, the psychic move.
That is weak to thinking.
No.
Fucking a weak ass bitch.
Why you flinch?
Alright, nice.
That's fine.
Flinch me once.
Full on me.
Flinch me twice.
Shame on you.
Oh man, my bullet bear!
Is there anything in here?
What's this?
Warning.
Dangerous.
Find different path.
Okay, I can do this.
Wait, I can do this.
What?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Last try.
No!
It was so close!
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
No!
Wait, I actually got it.
I actually got it.
Nice!
Oh my god, I did it.
Okay, guys, I- I- I- I- I- we don't need to fight.
I- I do not want to go back.
I- we don't need to fight.
We don't need to fight anybody.
I'll just say that.
Wait, what?
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, up!
Oh my god, it's up.
I couldn't see.
Guys, I don't have any more group.
I don't have any more gold shrooms.
I can't, guys.
There's no- I don't have gold shrooms anymore, guys.
I- I- I- I fed him so much.
I fed- he ate so much.
I- heh- he- heh- heh- heh- heh- heh.
He- he can't eat no more.
Nooo!
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, that's pretty bad.
Yeah, that's pretty bad.
It could lead hardра-
All right.
Klepto?
What's that?
Oh, it's a bird.
Bird versus bird.
But I have rock.
I have homewrecker.
Okay, that does nothing.
He has a super power?
That's fine.
Bro, what the fuck?
I just throw rocks.
This guy is Superman.
Alright, let's just use meter mash.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, that actually does more damage.
Okay.
What else is he sending?
Oh, I can just use grass.
I mean, not grass.
I can just use air slash.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Leave!
Breathe!
Yeah!
Okay.
Don't worry, Dad.
I still have more food for you.
Keep eating.
Keep eating, Dad.
It's not over yet.
I hear no bell.
Okay.
Oh, I...
Oh, we were here.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I...
Someone made it through Rainbow Road.
My car is definitely gonna need repairs after this.
Okay, I...
Oh my god.
I keep...
Actually, me here.
Okay.
No.
I keep forgetting which one was the heal one.
Alright.
You know what?
It was just a little...
I just had too many.
You know?
I had too many.
I just got...
I had to spend it somewhere.
Oh, yeah.
Let's make this a photo finish.
Okay.
Let's...
Let's beat up the cameraman real quick, fast.
Yeah.
This would be the Pokemon League.
Alright.
After we beat up the cameraman and buy some healing items, we'll call it here.
Since...
We're almost done...
Finishing...
We're almost finished the game anyway.
But I did say we're finishing it at...
Uh...
Oh wait.
He sent himself over.
We're finishing it on Wednesday.
I could finish the game today.
I could.
But then I could have the rest of my day to sleep.
I could...
What the fuck?
I believe in you.
I believe in you, son.
Okay.
And then he digs a hole.
Alright.
Get out.
That's fine.
I wanted him out anyway.
Alright.
Use the egg bomb.
Yay!
Alright.
Egg bomb him again.
Who is he gonna send?
Oh, he's gonna send himself out.
Wait.
What?
What's good against...
What's good against that?
I don't know.
Uh...
Donate.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's good against...
What's good against Latiku?
Fire or rock?
I'm risking it.
You got this dead!
You're clearly...
Oh, I don't think you're faster.
But like...
Oh.
Um...
You got this, son.
Look at you go.
Oh my god.
The fucking dig abuse.
I hate that shit.
Okay.
That's okay.
It does the damage we need.
Um...
Okay.
We got photo finish.
Alright.
We got the raid boss down.
Now I can send in my actual...
Wait.
Now we can send in data again.
Ba dum ba dum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum.
Yes!
Sit on that bean!
I'll never get tired of that.
Alright.
Last one.
Oh shit.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Dad.
Every time.
Every time he lives with one HP.
Yay!
Clutch, he takes those.
That was a fantastic battle.
Maybe I should have recorded it.
Perfect.
Now how about...
Super hide?
Super Mario?
Super jump for the camera!
Alright.
I think it really captured your essence.
Get it?
CrankyCon may have rubbed off after...
After recording his commie show.
Well.
Your photo's uploading.
Alright.
Let's heal.
That was...
Oh my gosh.
I sure do love gambling with Dad's life!
In game!
Okay.
Let's buy some...
Shrooms.
Get it from here?
No.
It's on the other side.
Alright.
Ultra Shroom.
Max.
Okay.
We need more...
We definitely need more of these.
These guys have actually clutched it for us.
And then...
Half HP.
Oh, we don't get like the...
Oh!
Okay.
Let's grab...
Wait.
Let's have something that raises 5.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Now he's unstoppable.
Where's the...
Oh, do I already have one?
Oh my god, I already had one.
I already have one!
It's 5.
Alright, we don't need more money.
Just have all...
Now you're...
Now you're actually unstoppable.
Some would say invincible.
Alright.
Let's head over to the...
Elite 4 right now.
Alright, and then we'll save.
Alright!
We'll call it here!
We'll finish...
Super Mario!
On Wednesday!
Now I'm taking a nap!
Ah!
Oh, I need to feed Dad and then...
I don't need to walk him...
What time do I walk him?
10...
11...
12...
1... 2... 3... 4... 5...
Okay, yeah, I need to walk him.
In an hour or two.
Alright, guys!
Thank you all for coming.
I always love streaming for you guys.
Um, we'll finish this game...
On Wednesday.
And then we'll finish...
Onimusha!
Tomorrow!
Too!
So thank you all for coming everyone!
I'm gonna rest a bit.
I gotta rest my voice.
Cause I have some...
Stuff I need to record.
But...
Thank you everybody for coming.
Um...
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Stay up for me.
Head to bend.
Cause...
You deserve it!
Alright guys, I'm gonna rest...
Rest up now.
I'm gonna take a little break...
Before I go back to work mode.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
We're almost at the end.
I've realized like...
The last couple of months...
I've been playing some...
Really, really, really long game series.
I remember in the past...
Like...
Usually games would take me like...
Three to four parts.
But I've been playing some...
Super duper long games.
I've never had...
Series before that would like...
Take like ten plus parts to complete.
But it's been...
It's been happening a lot often now.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Um...
But it has been fun.
It has been fun.
Um...
Anyway guys, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!